DEEPTO CHAKRABARTY: A pivoted
rod held horizontal, parallel
to the ground, and
released from rest
will simply fall, rotating
about the pivot point.
In particular, suppose
we have a mass attached
to one end of a pivoted rod.
So here is my pivot.
Here's my pivoted rod, which
we'll assume is massless.
And I have-- and
it has a length d,
and I attach a
mass m to one end.
If I let this go from
rest, it will simply
fall, rotating about the pivot
point, which I'll call s.
And it's easy to
understand that in terms
of the action of gravity
which is acting downward
and the resulting
torque about point s.
If I replace this point mass
with a wheel of the same mass,
so this disk is a
wheel with, let's say,
a radius r and the same mass
m attached to a pivoted rod.
The rod is massless
and has length d.
If I hold this horizontal,
parallel to the ground,
and release it from
rest, it will still just
fall to the ground.
Not a surprising result.
What is surprising is if
I then spin up the wheel,
so if I have the
wheel rotating about
its axle with some large
angular velocity, little omega,
and then I hold it horizontal,
parallel to the ground,
and release it from rest, then
remarkably this wheel plus axle
will not fall.
It will remain horizontal,
parallel to the ground.
But the center of
mass of the wheel
will execute a small circular
orbit about the vertical axis
through the pivot point.
This remarkable and
very non-intuitive
motion is called
precession and the system
that's undergoing precession
is called a gyroscope.
Let's see if we can
understand this behavior
in terms of the angular
momentum of the system.
So what I've drawn here is
a side view of the system.
So let's define
some coordinates.
So we have r-hat in the
radial outward direction,
k-hat in the direction of the
z-axis, the vertical axis.
And then we'll define theta-hat
pointing into the screen.
OK, so that's a side view.
I'd like to now draw a top view.
So let's say we're looking
down along the z-axis
from the top on the system.
So now here is my
pivot point, and here
is a top view of my wheel.
Again, this is a distance d.
Now this is still
the r-hat direction.
This is the theta-hat direction.
And the k-hat direction. is
pointing out of the screen.
Let's draw the forces
acting on our diagram here.
So the weight is acting at the
center of mass of the wheel.
That's mg downward.
And there's a normal
force acting upwards
at the pivot point.
The torque is just
given by r cross f,
and so relative to
point s at the distance
d times the weight mg.
So the torque is mgd.
And by doing r cross f
with the right hand rule,
we see that it's directed in
the plus theta-hat direction.
Now again, let's
suppose that I'm
holding the wheel horizontal
and release it from rest.
If the wheel is not spinning--
so this is not rotating,
this is a stationary wheel
that I'm holding horizontal,
and I release it from rest,
then its initial
angular momentum,
with respect to point s, is 0.
Over a short time
interval, delta t,
the torque which is acting
in the theta-hat direction,
will cause an angular impulse or
change in the angular momentum.
That change in angular
momentum, delta l vector,
is equal to the torque
times that short time
interval, delta t.
And it will act in the
theta-hat direction.
The change in
angular momentum will
be in the theta-hat direction
because that's the direction
that the torque is in.
So for this case--
and by the way, this view here,
I should have labeled this.
This is a top view.
So this is the side view.
This is the top view
of the same system.
So the torque is mgd in
the theta-hat direction.
So in the side view, that's
going into the screen.
And in the top view, that's
going pointing upward.
That's the theta-hat direction.
So in the case where
the wheel is not
spinning, if we think
about the top view,
the initial angular
momentum is 0.
Right?
So I'll just draw that as a dot.
So that's l initial equals 0.
And then I add a small torque,
or small angular impulse
due to the torque,
delta l, which
is in the theta-hat direction.
So that's pointing in
the theta-hat direction.
So that's my delta l.
And when I sum those
together, I start out with 0.
I add a small delta l.
So my final angular momentum,
a time delta t later,
is just equal to my delta l.
So this is l final.
And that's pointing in
the theta-hat direction.
So a torque in the
theta-hat direction,
into the screen
for the side view,
is consistent with the
wheel falling down.
So with theta-hat
pointing into the screen,
the wheel will
basically fall this way.
It's rotating about point s.
And that's consistent
with the torque pointing
in the theta-hat direction.
Now as the wheel
falls, the torque
continues to point in
the theta-hat direction.
And so the angular
acceleration will increase.
Now what happens if this wheel
is not stationary, but instead
is spinning rapidly?
In that case, the
torque remains the same.
It's still mgd in the
theta-hat direction.
But now the initial
angular momentum is not 0.
Rather it is a very large vector
pointing along the spin axis.
Let's choose the
sense of rotation
such that l points in
the plus r-hat direction.
That's actually the
way I've drawn it here.
So in that case, the
angular momentum vector
initially points in the
plus r-hat direction.
So then what happens over
a short time, delta t?
So now let's consider the case
where the wheel is spinning.
So now my initial
angular momentum
is a large vector pointing
in the r-hat direction.
That's l initial.
I'm adding a small
perpendicular vector, delta l,
in the theta-hat direction.
And so the sum of
those two things,
if this is the original r-hat
direction, what's happened
is that my new vector is at
a small angle with respect
to the original r-hat direction.
I'll call that
angle delta theta.
So what I've done is I've
rotated my initial angular
momentum vector by a small angle
without changing its length.
Notice the two very
different situations.
In one case, I start out
with 0 angular momentum.
And all the angular
momentum I end up with
comes from the angular
impulse due to the torque.
In the second case, where
the wheel is spinning,
I start out with a very large
initial angular momentum.
I then add a small
angular impulse,
small compared to my
initial angular momentum,
in the perpendicular direction.
And that causes not a change
in the length of the vector,
but a change in its direction.
Which means that the angular
momentum vector rotates.
That's why the
system precesses when
the wheel is rotating rapidly.
Before we can understand
precession more carefully,
it'll be useful to review
the mathematics of rotating
vectors.
So first, suppose we have
a vector that I'll call r1.
And I'm going to add a
vector delta r to this.
And I'm going to
have the condition
that the length of
delta r is much,
much smaller than the length
of my original vector r1,
and that delta r is
perpendicular to R1.
So here's my delta r.
And so if I add
these two vectors,
let's say r2 is the
sum of r1 plus delta r,
so that's my vector r2.
And I'm going to call
this angle delta theta.
And now few things to note.
First of all, since this
is a right triangle,
notice that the length
r2 is equal to r1 divided
by the cosine of delta theta.
But if that angle is small, if
delta theta is a small angle,
then cosine theta is
well approximated by 1,
and so this is just
my original length r1.
And since r1 is equal to r2,
I'm just going to call that--
call them both r.
And this is for
small delta theta.
So that tells us that
the vector just rotates.
When I have a large vector,
and I add a small perpendicular
vector, the result is to
rotate the original vector
without changing its length.
As long as the angle is
small or, equivalently, as
long as delta r is very small
compared to my original vector
length, I'll get
a pure rotation.
In addition, again
looking at this triangle,
notice that delta r is
equal to [AUDIO OUT], which
I can describe as r, times
the sine of delta theta.
And again, if the
angle is small,
if delta theta's a
small angle, then this
is well approximated by
r times the angle delta
theta in radians.
And again, this is
for small delta theta.
So now if I divide
this last equation
by delta t, small time interval
in which this rotation is
happening, then I write this
as delta r vector divided
by delta t.
And I take the
magnitude of that.
That is equal to r delta
theta divided by delta t.
And if I go to the limit
as delta t gets small,
as delta t approaches
0, then I can write this
as the derivative of the
vector r, the time derivative,
I should say the
magnitude of the time
derivative of vector r.
And that's equal to the length
r times the time derivative
of the angle d theta dt.
But d theta dt is just
the angular velocity.
So I could write that
as r times capital omega
for the angular velocity.
And this is just
our familiar result
that for circular motion, for
the rotation of a position
vector, the velocity
is equal to the radius
of the circle times the angular
velocity of the rotation.
Another way of
thinking of that is
that the magnitude of the
rate of change of the position
vector, which we
call the velocity,
is equal to the length
of the rotating vector
r times the angular
velocity of the rotation.
But there's nothing special
about the position vector
that I used in order
to do this analysis.
So if instead of a position
vector I considered any vector,
so let's say this is my
rotational motion of a vector
that I'll call A. So
that's A at time t.
And then at some later time,
that's A of t plus delta t.
This vector is my delta A. I'll
call this angle delta theta.
And so the vector A is
rotating in that direction
with an angular
velocity capital omega.
Now in the example I just did,
my vector A is actually r of t.
But so everywhere
where I have an r here,
I can just write an A. This
is now just an arbitrary
vector in space that is rotating
at an angular velocity capital
omega.
And what we see, using
the same analysis,
we would find that the magnitude
of the time rate of change
of the vector, of
the rotating vector,
is equal to the length of
the rotating vector, which
is A, times d theta dt.
Or in other words, the
length of the rotating
vector times the angular
velocity of the rotation.
That's true for any vector.
OK?
This is a general
result. v equals
r omega is just a special
case of this general rule
where, in that case, my rotating
vector is a position vector.
But this is true for any vector
that's rotating in space.
In particular for a
rotating angular momentum--
for a rotating angular
momentum vector,
I have that the magnitude of the
time derivative of the rotating
angular momentum vector is
just equal to the length
of the angular momentum vector,
the magnitude of the angular
momentum, times the angular
velocity of rotation.
Now in addition, in the
particular case of a rotating
angular momentum vector or of
any angular momentum vector
rather, we know that the time
derivative of the angular
momentum vector is also
equal to the torque vector.
So I can set these
two things equal.
In the case of a rotating
angular momentum vector,
the magnitude of
the torque is given
by the magnitude of the
rotating angular momentum
vector times the angular
speed of rotation.
And that's just using
the general behavior
of a rotating vector in space.